oh
je détiens taux au comptant à mobiliser
tous les autres cette image de
retrouvailles a beaucoup ému la
population vous quand vous repensez à 7
à ce moment là qu'est ce qui vous vient
encore quand j'ai vu était comme moi où
le soleil est sorti puis c'est pour moi
vous mon mari aussi est elle même choisi
le véhicule même chose on est parler de
soi après c'est au rayon de soleil notre
fille je prends un certain que toutes
les parts hey espérer dans le retrouver
en rien ça l'est parce que chaque enfant
pour chaque parent est un rayon de
soleil il tout le monde amis
c'est à vous
pour tous volontaires et ont boudé
qu'est ce qu'ils voudront mais chaque
bord si oui mais beaucoup de gens il
manque beaucoup d'amour demande beaucoup
de ces pas de connexion c'est pas nos
villes un jour on va le retrouver
- se trompent pas quand on vous souhaite
fois à vous et à tous l'histoire lac
mégantic pour la prochaine année
est ce que tout le monde retrouve leurs
belles lumières